- [Mark] All right, Helia.
Helia, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Helia] I was born in
the Azores in Portugal.
- [Mark] And where'd you grow up?
- [Helia] I was brought up
in Lowell, Massachusetts.
- [Mark] Tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- I was brought up by
my grandmother, grandfather,
until I was seven.
And from seven to 16,
I stayed with my parents and got pregnant.
Went on my own.
Stayed in Massachusetts
til my son was nine
and been out here the rest of the time.
Now he's grown up.
And I've been out here for 21 years
and didn't even call
my family for 20 years.
They thought I was dead.
And just time goes by really fast
when you're not doing right,
and the number one reason
why homeless people
don't contact their family
is because of shame.
And it was so wrong.
My grandparents are dead
and my mom and dad, they're
in their late eighties
they just went back to Portugal.
They came and visit me.
I have five sisters, I'm the oldest.
And it feels good to have
a family after so long.
- [Mark] So you're still
in touch with everyone?
- Yeah, I just talked to my sisters.
We all get together on the phone
and they were coming to visit
me until this corona sickness.
Now they just stay in the house.
- [Mark] What is your drug today?
- I smoke crack.
- [Mark] And you've been
doing that since when?
- Since I was 17.
- [Mark] How'd you first
get turned onto crack?
- I started doing lines of
powder cocaine back East.
We started cooking it, it was freebasing.
And now it's just fake.
Fake stuff that everybody's addicted to.
But I don't really like getting high,
It's not fun anymore.
It's maintenance.
Back East, we used to go camping,
over here it's called survival.
And they used to call
us white trailer trash,
and now I say trailer trash wannabe.
I would love to have my big trailer
we used to go camping in.
I can live there all year long.
I just gotta get myself
together and go to rehab
and start all over.
- [Mark] So your son is how old now?
- My son was born in 1987.
He's 33.
- [Mark] You raised him
for part of his life?
- Until he was nine.
- [Mark] That's when the
drugs kind of took hold?
- [Helia] Yeah, his dad
kept him home from school,
and then the state came in
and he was drinking
and drug paraphernalia.
He let this Brazilian lady in
and after that I couldn't leave the dad.
But I was working and I
could pass a drug test
but his dad couldn't.
So they were about to take my son.
So I called Debbie, his aunt,
and she took temporary custody of him.
And she brought him up
right, he went to college.
I'm like 75% sure that if I would have
brought him out here with me,
he'd end up on the streets.
Being with her, he went to college.
He doesn't do drugs.
He drinks now because
dad died two years ago,
but still a truck driver.
He drives an 18-wheeler and I'm proud.
I talk to him on the phone now
and it's just good to have family back.
- [Mark] It's good that he's
not living on the streets.
- [Helia] Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's smart.
He's going to work and I'm just glad that,
I mean I missed him all
these years and stuff,
but I'm glad that he was brought up right.
- [Mark] How do you support
yourself living here?
- I got food stamps, GA,
hustling the streets,
shoplifting, mostly I do distraction.
Like I'll go in and knock down shelves
and my friends get to it.
It's not right, but it is what it is.
- [Mark] What do you think
people that don't do drugs
that watch these kind of
videos, watch these stories,
don't understand about addiction?
- They don't, unless you've
been there, you have no idea.
It's just sad.
I tell the kids,
I say, "Go to school, do your homework,
listen to your parents, don't drink,
don't do drugs, go to
college, get a degree,
don't end up like these people
sleeping on the street."
And I just hope that maybe
just five out of a hundred
make it to college just
because they heard,
"Hey, who's that crazy lady saying that?"
If you just live right and go to college
and get a degree and don't
do drugs, you got it made.
If you don't, you fall
into alcohol and drugs.
It pretty much takes a lot
of years out of your life.
- [Mark] How do you think this lifestyle
has changed you over the years?
- Made me numb.
I gotta drink and do
drugs just to become numb
and made me tougher,
like I'm pretty much fearless,
like I go out there at two,
three o'clock in the morning
just like in the middle of the afternoon
and somebody like me
shouldn't really be out there
with all the pro creatures, I call them.
I consider myself pretty street smart
which is nothing to be proud about.
But you learn how to survive
and you learn who the gang members are,
you learn who like the OGs, the top guys,
and you learn how they
are and who they are,
and then you start hanging with them
and you're pretty much protected
because they'll say, "Don't mess with her.
She's like one of us."
But I don't belong to no gang.
I'm just me on one team.
- [Mark] What would you
say to a young person
who's considering going
down this kind of path?
- Oh man.
I hate seeing the girls half my age.
Just don't do it.
Don't fall because once you
fall, it's hard to get up.
But I see a lot of them walking with,
I know where they're going,
who they're going with,
what they're going to do,
and how they're going to feel afterwards.
But I really can't do nothing about it
because I have to walk
around on these streets.
It's sad, but a lot of times,
I'll say, "Your mom just
paid me $50 to come get you.
You got to come with me
and she's going to give me another $50."
And it's all just a lie
just to get them away
from whoever they're with.
The other day my little
friend was getting into a car
and it was undercover cop.
And right before she got in, I grabbed her
and I'm like, "Your mom
wants you, come with me."
And she was mad.
But once she knew that he was police,
then she loved me.
And I go around saving
these little youngsters,
they're smoking fentanyl,
and they're just dying like flies.
Like I walked by and these little kids
turning blue and nobody's even,
like everybody's just walking
by and not even acknowledged.
It's just another homeless people,
but it's somebody's son,
it's somebody's daughter.
I carry my purse with Narcan.
Just last month I saved five of them.
And it's funny because
after you save them,
you give them this Narcan,
they can't get high for 72 hours,
so they get so mad.
It's like, bitch you're mad
at me for saving your life?
They don't understand
until this one little girl,
she went to jail and she had
been there for six months,
and then I ended up in there
and she's like, "Oh, Boston, I
love you. You saved my life."
But like for the whole time
that she was on the street, she was mad.
You don't really realize
until the smoke clears.
Lot of times when I go to jail,
three, four days, over
the weekend and stuff,
the smoke clears.
And when I come out,
I go straight to the Woman's Place
and I want to go upstairs to rehab.
But they say, "No, come back tomorrow."
And I know that if I
leave, I'll just smoke.
And then I won't be back tomorrow.
But the last three times,
they actually had to call the police,
and it was funny because the police,
I give them a hard time and
I'm kind of wise when I drink,
and police were like, "Please,
please keep her there."
And just once I go back
out there, it's over.
- [Mark] What's one of
the most horrible things
you've seen down here in the Tenderloin?
- Pretty much, my best friend
getting stabbed to death.
And there was nothing I could do about it.
And then police wanted me to tell on
the people that stabbed him,
but once you snitch on those guys,
you pretty much either have
to leave or end up dead.
So they wanted me to point them out,
but half of them like went
back to their own country.
Drug dealers and stuff.
It was pretty bad because after
he couldn't breathe anymore,
I was in that circle,
and I got weak, like, Oh my God,
cause they will kill you
just so you don't talk.
But I got strength and I just ran.
After that, it was pretty
much just suffering it out.
It was my best friend and now he's gone,
but it is what it is.
- [Mark] Do you have regrets
about any parts of your life?
- Yeah.
I wish I didn't keep my family
worried about me for 20 years,
but there's nothing I
can do about that now.
But I just make it up to them
by visiting when they want to visit
and calling them all the time
and just keeping in touch.
That's all they want is
for me to be all right.
- [Mark] All right Helia,
thank you so much for talking with me.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Good luck with
whatever you do next.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Thanks.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] That was great.
- [Mark] You're a beautiful speaker.